mr deb what does this reflect
um
sorry
it appears to be the agreement
um
of
pirates four and
five
competent compensation and
merchandise
mr deb at this time how many other
franchise films have you been a part of
um at that time alice alice in
wonderland
um
oh boy
um i was in wonderland
um
i'm so
pathetic when it comes to knowing what
movies i've done i'm sorry i i just
i don't watch them
i
feel better not watching them um
i couldn't like
i mean
what was the question again
how many i'm going to order in the court
or i will have you removed understood
thank you
how many other franchise films had you
been a part of at the time of this
contract
there was a third there was there was
pirates
there was um
oh sorry um
with warner brothers uh
fantastic beasts and where to find them
and then crimes of grindelwald
and how does the compensation reflected
in this contract compared to that
what you receive for the other
franchises that you've been a part of
objection foundation
he just established that he was a member
of other franchise films at this point
and
he hasn't established a foundation that
he knows how he was compensated for
all of rule of direction if you can
answer
um
i believe
um
the compensation obviously all the
pay and
back end and all those things are
negotiated by
agents lawyers and this was
comparatively this this was
this is my salary on that film
[Music]
and other other salaries were of a
similar
of a similar
status i suppose
uh if i could direct your attention to
the 12th page of the document
yes
cool
uh is this your signature mr dab
yes it is okay we can take this down
thank you
mr deb i i recall that you testified
that you don't know
during a given period what movies you
were working on so my question is who
would know that
um
well first and foremost my agent
or agents
i do recall a couple of the other films
that i'd made after
one was
initially called richard says goodbye
and that was uh
they changed the name to the professor
and uh
during all of the
the um
nastiness over the past uh
six years
uh
that film went straight to uh
pay-per-view
um there was
um
another film
called minimada that was produced uh
uh it was
my my company uh infinitum
nile uh
we had uh developed a film called
minamata about eugene smith
and uh
the minamata
uh
uh the well the the the the mercury
poisoning of of a very small fishing
village in um
southern japan
um
there was that one and then there was a
film
called
um
waiting for the barbarians with uh
one
mark rylance um and robert pattins and
um
those were three films that i'd done